wait wait wait bro if a woman has 100
control over who get or who gets born
right yeah you have no control of that
so yeah I understand so if you so if a
woman gets pregnant yes and and you want
that baby I have no saying that okay and
then if you don't want that baby you
still have no say in it yeah how is that
not 100 controlled and selfish no I'm
saying if the girl wants to have the
baby right
how is that selfish if she has a baby
and she feels like it's right well if
you don't no because I don't have any
control in this stuff
to have sex with someone and I'll take
an older responsibility I'm having sex
with you if I have a baby with you then
I'm gonna take all that